en el 106 de la inversión rusa el
destino del donbass podría definirse en
la batalla por severo donestsk es lo que
afirma el presidente ucraniano volodymyr
selenski los rusos intentan cortar los
suministros a las fuerzas ucranianas que
existen por todos los medios como aquí
en el borde de esta carretera
estratégica a unos 50 kilómetros más al
sur de
el cráter es demasiado pequeño para un
ataque aéreo parece más un cráter de un
vehículo cohete
según kiev severodonezk ha caído en gran
medida bajo el control de moscú y de las
fuerzas separatistas los combates siguen
siendo intensos sabes 38.1 esto nokia
para resumir la situación en los
principales teatros de operaciones en
agresor continúa la ofensiva e intentar
rodear a nuestras tropas en la región de
severo de angelis y chance y bloquear
las principales rutas logísticas que
los ataques aéreos fuegos de artillería
despliegue de un número creciente de
tropas los rusos y sus aliados lo
apuestan todo para controlar esta ciudad
a costa de una gran destrucción como
muestran estas imágenes de satélite
posiciones que les permitan bombardear
masivamente la ciudad vecina de
licitantes al otro lado del río las
fuerzas ucranianas también esperan que
moscú utilice misiles de largo alcance
para atacar severodonezk y sus
alrededores